[Music]
we'll take our leave and
[Music]
[Music]
and one day
we'll take our leave and go
hello welcome friends
what is up i
thought that today i would
uh i finished work a lot later than i
planned to i was planning to stream this
game yesterday
but also i guess i've been trying to be
careful with my hands because they don't
work very well
um but i finished work late and then
took a nap
and then thought that i would stream for
a couple hours or maybe an hour i don't
know we'll see how i feel
i'm definitely not off work tomorrow no
um for anyone watching on youtube
i set the chat there to members only
i will be reading the twitch chat unless
you're a youtube member then i'll still
see your chats
um switch chat's just a bit more fun
it's what i realized uh okay let me open
the chat up properly
so yeah i've been really excited about
this game um i'm a huge fan of plupa
team i am playing on the xbox series x
um
and okay cool
well yeah zoe so i i walked late took a
nap
well fell asleep i didn't intend to take
the nap and then woke up and so i'll
just have less sleep for tomorrow
basically
okay let's play this game this full
disclosure could hurt my hands a little
bit
i'm not sure um
this is my first time actually properly
attempting to play a video game and i
think i'm okay as long as i like keep my
hands like this
like it's just very far from the gamepad
i think i'll be all right
but yeah very excited about this game um
how to help but how uh-huh
seems fine it seems fine subtitles on
text size
can't go lodge
or people watch it at home
okay cool new game
let's do it i turned my lights off by
the way which is why the
webcam looks awful um because i figured
that i wanted an extra spooky stream
it all starts with a dead girl not off
to a great start
not quite what we wanted
okay this is fine this seems fine
she looks alive to me i feel misled
that is clearly an alive girl you
you sold me something and did not
deliver
you kill her or i'm gonna
file a zero out of ten i'm better critic
he seemed so chill what did you do
the victim blaming right out the gate i
don't know she's probably asking for it
that's all i'm saying
okay well now i'm spooked i just picked
up tea at the same time that that kettle
boiled
that's the spookiest thing that's
happened so far dream
i'm shook it's the end of summer
girls running through the woods
the moon the scent of pines
and then the gunshot
is she the little girl did you live
was that misled that's messed up
always felt so real who are you talking
to the blood on my
cheek the cold sweat the dream got it
got it got it got it you lied to me
i'd managed to convince myself or did i
misunderstand
no it must always be a lie even if i'm
misunderstood it's not my fault couldn't
possibly be my fault
that wasn't the only part i thought you
were hot until i saw you smoking
and your hands are a bit dirty too love
no wonder people used to think i was
strange
if they only knew
well this is already very different to
most of blue team's games for the record
they make uh
layers of fear when the phone rang
and they made blair witch hardest day of
my life
um i love layers of fear it wasn't so
hot on blair witch blairwitch
this is certainly their best looking
game i would think too
but i still liked blackwatch dress him
up for his last journey
the people who want to like like this oh
yeah observers
simple hello fake christopher i'm doing
okay just the time i did every day my
hands are sore my arms hurt
but uh doing pretty good thank you but
looking through it is it not officially
out this little claw name
i needed a moment oh it would be
together
soon at least um i did get a code i
should disclose that blooper team did
send me a code
i've actually had it since monday and
was planning to stream earlier but yeah
ended up
like i said working late and then
sleeping so midnight it is
but yeah i've been following this game
really closely and talking about it on
the channel for a long time so i am i
was almost ready i definitely always
wanted to stream it
i just had to find his special tie clip
i should have been paying a lot more
attention to all of that um
chat you are welcome to call me out on
talking to you instead of
paying attention to what she was
actually saying but
i have this beef especially as
someone who writes things with um
monologues that don't involve action i
think oh
am i supposed to look at this further i
think if you're going to monologue
pair it with an action don't have you
just standing there you know um not a
fan
cause people don't just stand and speak
unless it's to a therapist which i guess
she also could have been and once again
i am blaming her for misunderstanding
myself rather than for her own
uh i also say [ __ ] whenever i see a cat
as i am deeply allergic
nice to see you too
jack's room it's like he never
i'm weird i'm a weirdo he didn't mind my
weirdness
he kept telling me i was special yeah
it's like a deep emotional allergicness
to
cats yes he's agent 47.
[Laughter]
cool specs bro you some kind of nerd
jack was a humble religious man
he ran a funeral home and i'd help out
whenever i could
it felt good to be useful
keep hissing at me you just roasted
yourself pretty bad do you think's gonna
feed you
yeah no i'm not gonna feed that stupid
cat
again not my fault the not the i mean
not the cat's faults the
whole sentences that i'm allergic to
them but here i am blaming them anyway
oh this is so much and i feel compelled
to explore all of it
no we're not doing it i'm sorry but
nourishing nope but what if there's an
achievement for it
someone just asked me if i tie my hair
up often
i do yeah because it gets annoying but
spencer good boy spencer is always a
good boy
i had to go in a
vehicle today and i asked how do i
interact with this one i asked my good
friend ethan nestor to drive me home
that's why i'm back on cyberpunk chair
nobody panic i'm back home um
i did not throw the chair out and i
asked ethan to drive me because he's
very socially distanced and i didn't
want to get an anuma i guess i forgot
and i asked him to bring spencer and he
did
i can do it now what is this just blank
piece of paper
all right all right then
hang on is this like do any of them have
anything okay no swoo
what is this a no
how about here photo for five seconds
okay so then this one first maybe
let me go no
eliminate the photo for five seconds
first okay how do i put it there though
this might all be fake but none of it
may mean anything
i'm not sure how to put it there or is
it just
maybe i put it there first ah it is okay
got it there
two three four five
huh okay
cool i did do this in high school you
know i wonder if they still teach people
how to do this
um okay two
three great great great cool cool cool
one two three
oh
i feel like it's probably not taught
anymore but yeah
what's the last photo i took of you jack
that's a good picture
she did a good job
ah i suspect she may have done this
before
okay
i have to find a tie clip i guess still
ah damn my compulsion i want to find
everything also
can anyone in chat tell me so i don't
have to look through the
the um huh
um i don't have to look through the
achievements if there is an achievement
for feeding the cat
please anybody because
i don't want to see spoilers but i would
like to know if i'm missing an
achievement
okay cool not that way
i will not feed the cat unless i gain
arbitrary points in order to do so
how dare you there is an achievement i
guess you could be lying to me
so what would i know anyway i'm gonna do
it
and i think you might be lying
the things that i do for potentially
five games school right
okay i didn't i was just paying not even
paying attention you guys and just i
don't even want to go in there yet hang
on where's the kitchen
i was just not paying attention to the
this is it not that one
no okay i feel like the kitchen was here
but then it's just that was it here
i don't want to feed this stupid cat
i'm doing it here you go what's your
face
glad to see you're still kicking around
thank you
[Laughter]
and it was 20 as well i expected like
five
oh you love to see it you'd love to see
i should i
why did i ever think you were lying to
me you know i should never
i i should never have doubted you
uh interesting beautiful
beautiful beautiful beautiful it just
seemed like a thing
that would be an achievement jack's tie
clip
i need to find it that's right yes
okay so it's not in there i feel like
it's probably in his office but i just
don't know where in his office i also
haven't really looked in this room
this is where i started though isn't it
i was just stupid thai clippy stupid
dick
i didn't read any of this but i also
don't want to it's fine
is there a room i have never been into
you can't go anywhere look at her cool
jacket though also she has no butt
absence of butt it's a real shame
these devs just keep you know making our
women ugly and
hang on what hang on hang on a minute oh
i have not been through this door that's
right
cool
weird to be back in my old room
so many memories
does she talk out loud i have no butt i
definitely have but i'm sorry i will
challenge you on that
i used to have a thing for them don't
know why
really i guess they just used to make me
happy
jack but they're dead so it's kind of
[ __ ] up that's why there's so many of
them here
we do have really pretty butterflies in
australia they always talk about the
the negatives of all the animals in
australia we have very pretty
butterflies
oh yeah my cam is like this on purpose
for the record it is supposed to look
spooky
i'm sorry if you considered her not
having a butt to be body shaped kids
from the orphanage
not all of them had my luck i feel like
you're allowed to have opinions
but uh definitely not my intention to do
that
to take care of to listen
that was the least i could do
she's also not real
we do not have deadly butterflies no
we have really pretty butterflies
seriously look up a ulysses butterfly
they are absolutely beautiful
my oldest family heirloom
as a kid i'd show this to people just to
freak them out
i'd usually say something like pretty
sick huh
nice that was such a great pun
i was trying to read it off the thing
and i didn't need to do that i should
just read it here
second degree thermal burns covering 35
of the total body surface area trunk and
upper limbs area
suspected inhalation injury
i burnt my feet when i was a kid really
bad
i would have been like one or two i
don't remember it but i was hospitalized
and had to like have my feet in bandages
and all that stuff
and um i have no scars or anything
but i imagine it was pretty terrifying
from my parents
it's like wild that you can sustain an
injury that bad and just have like
no recollection of it at all yeah i was
walking on calls
uh asylum i usually read the youtube
live chat
i have i don't know his [ __ ] tie clip
is dude
um i put it on members only for for
today
but yes if anyone is a member and chat's
in there i will see it
where is your tie clip sir is there
anywhere i've not been
what's that it's the one let me go in
there
what
no i went in here and did i do this one
i think i did but i didn't
i did um okay have i missed something
obvious has anyone seen a
a bloody tie clip
i don't know why it would be in the
kitchen
i'm also maybe not looking the right way
i'm just looking for the big old x's
like could it maybe be in the newspaper
huh huh it's not
oh thank you um i'm not sure how to
pronounce your name the person who said
i love your web team thank you
i cannot take credit for it um obviously
i did
the voice work and uh that was a ton of
fun but even then it was like
you know having a good director makes a
very big difference
um
but uh yeah fully written by
one marvin w i believe he's french
i feel like i'm just going around in
circles
uh it's not the gone home studio the
gone home studio is fulbright
who most recently made tacoma
room to the left before your room is
that this room
is this room because that's all i've
seen in here
why you put a tie clip you stupid [ __ ]
i don't know game is definitely not
scary yet no we're just walking around
the house
try here again did i forget something in
here maybe
i don't feel like i did that
no i've interacted with all of these
things
i didn't realize i could do that so
nope i don't know where it is below the
clock on the table
oh in here you're saying
there's no clock here do you mean in the
other room
go back to the desk what which desk
this desk the other table which tape
which
this table haha
you call that a desk come on now
thank you okay troy actually is in this
game
that's the other way
okay so it's still not here what the
[ __ ]
no there you are cool
okay there's something else i had to do
though isn't there
okay i think okay appreciate that
thank you that's not a desk that's
objectively not a desk
can we all agree a desk that is not
we lived upstairs from jack's funeral
home oh yes
it wasn't as weird as it said no she's
not talking
if it wasn't for that i may never have
learned to use my powers
this is um it feels more like a don't
nod game
than i would have expected
bigger environments though
okay let's go
jack taught me to accept my
condition condition all my foster
parents
he was the only one who saw control was
vibrating i'm not sure
why
[Music]
hmm
doing a big old vibrate
but i don't know why
hmm
is it this bike
i don't know i don't know
i guess it could be the rain i hadn't
considered that
but it feels very aggressive
i don't know
um okay
either that or i missed something
yes this totally has resident evil
silent hill-ish vibes
jack's in the prep room
do i walk you is that what the
insinuation is yes hello yes yeah
weird i don't remember locking it well
that's spooky
the key should be in the office
is nobody else here
[Music]
let me come back around just wait a
minute we're gonna
damn it the chat oh my gosh oh
gosh oh heck okay
thank you
cool i really didn't expect that
buddy okay
adam nowak
brutal
ah yes happy family
wait i thought i could interact with
that am i i suppose not
it's just glinting occasionally is that
what it is
[Music]
it is there's just occasionally a light
on jesus um okay
i'm liking this music
nothing okay let's keep going then
yeah i like the music a lot
[Music]
yeah uh awesome i feel like
by virtue of having worked in games
press i get uh
achievements that other people don't
have pretty often and it makes it less
special
um
that's the exit that room just didn't
look like an office but
perhaps it is um this one
visitation room is not an office that is
the office wait wait did i pick up a key
am i just like blanking because i'm
tired there was a key on that desk
wasn't there
that i picked up correct
cool
okay
all right let's go
oh depth of field
is very dark i can't see [ __ ]
[Music]
not sure if i'm ready yeah i don't know
why you wouldn't hire someone else to do
this love
i don't feel like you need to be the one
to do it
hey jack i've played too many games
where that's scary
when you open the thing until it pops
out
okay
buddy what am i supposed to do now
cool jacket
i'm just walking around walking around
looking at stuff
okay is there how do i like you what
else do i need to do
haha no i got your special clip
no gotcha where's your tie gotcha
find man's tie oh it's right there
yep look how resident evil you are
okay cool snazzy you wouldn't have it
any other way
look at me go playing a video game look
at it look at it
easy i guess i didn't know what to
expect
when things get personal it
just burned you from the inside out
there i guess you're ready
i really would hire someone else to do
this
that's like that's a whole mess
just traumatic
for all of us not just you protagonist
ruff
oh can't you people read
the signs that's closed spooky
spooks is it jack
is he if oh my gosh
that's a lot of darkness
okay okay okay oh god
well i'm not a fan of that
[Music]
oh my god okay this is fine everything's
fine everything's fine everything's fine
oh god it's fine it's just a dog
funeral what's the problem with that
[Music]
well
just what i wanted what the hell
check upstairs there's a staircase
oh you want me to go back like to my
like outside and upstairs so are you
telling me
ooh i like that
no oh oh great oh this is
wonderful this is exactly what i wanted
[Music]
no there's no staircase anyway i guess
it's maybe it means that it wanted me to
check up here
damn i guess you felt it too
what was that it's a cat what was that
and then it happened as it did so many
times when i thought my day couldn't get
any worse
oh where
is that our notebook it's chat i'm gonna
be late
i need to find that marianne
oh mary hannah
are you are you crying my child why is
his head look like a christmas tree
i
it's fine jack now you didn't happen to
see my notebook
did you darling i ain't seen [ __ ] dude
memories of it
stop talking to me so much for aging
gracefully
listen jack
you should probably get some rest forget
the notebook she would look insane
no no i've got so much work trying to
stop using that
she would look let it go deranged
i don't know how to say that the correct
way
you are crying what's wrong with you
nice hair color though
why is it so cold
[Music]
but why is he supposed to sleep there's
no beds
it's time to get some rest what's the
plan
yeah no i i
i'm worried about the surgery when i'm
at the hospital
are you sure you're going to be alright
yeah the split screen thing is super
interesting it's going to be fine
i'm curious to see how it plays out in
gameplay which is one of the things that
really interested me about this game
i promised myself once i would never let
anything happen to you
not while i'm around i'll be
fine i promise
no risky stuff man right
i would love to talk to them about how
they made this game it's super
interesting
i love you my child i've loved you since
the moment you walked into my life
remember that
well that's nice thank you i appreciate
that stranger
i find you extremely creepy but that
doesn't mean i'm not capable of taking a
compliment
oh my god oh gosh people would give
anything to have that opportunity
to say all the things that were left
unsaid
it's just a bit much but it didn't make
things any easier
i could help a thousand souls cross over
but when it came to jack
it still hurt like hell of course it did
i love you too daddy
was a dad confirmed
i used to think everyone saw the world
the way i did
divided torn between two
nah that's all you king oh
what is it some sort of kahlua situation
some sort of i was the only one like a
whiskey like a
what's she drinking it looks like
whiskey to me
or so i thought
we're closed comically launched across
town
i can't give you the number marianne
who is this you don't know me marianne
but i know you oh was the question if
it's early access
um this is the full game okay
but yes i do have it early what you are
what who is this my name
is thomas your phone is huge
listen if that's all you've got i'm no
there's more
i can give you the answers you've been
looking for your whole life
sir this is a wendy's i need you to
trust me trust you
i don't even know it all starts
with a dead girl
what did you say the neva resort find me
there
please i think the neo is probably the
[Music]
i would not go i'd report that dude do
the cops
and then dox him just for fun get dunked
on me
wanna give your phone number to twitter
right to the internet
woo i do really like blueber team
just think that their their approach to
a horror game is um
particularly unique
i have not beaten the game king blades
this is my first time playing it
i've had the game technically since
monday but
i haven't been able to play video games
blooper team are european yes
i'm all right thank you sam doing okay
yeah they're polish correct
[Music]
um there is a hands command that i put
on
twitch but um
[Music]
yeah my hands are still pretty sore this
is hurting which is a shame i hoped that
i'd be back to being able to play video
games it's been three weeks now since i
hurt myself but it does so hard sadly
i think i'll be fine it just means i
can't play for a long time
um and i was gonna wrap my hands in
bandages for the stream but i didn't end
up doing it because i did it so late so
maybe if i
try to stream again this week i really
want to do the resident evil demo
um maybe if i bandage myself it'll be a
bit better
i don't know but i also shouldn't push
it because then
i'm just going to make it worse so
careful
but very happy to be playing this game
yeah i imagine it's pretty short
the games are usually like five or six
hours
i like that song too
uh thank you rare achievement
appreciate ya
i feel like they made them a little bit
less noisy they used to be
and off i went like aggressively loud
like jump scare
loud whenever you got in the gym just
slightly better
but i've learned to trust my instincts
and there was something about this guy
laughed out loud at that comment mighty
bush he said it'll be hard playing the
recent people with them anyways because
he'll be playing with one hand seem to
know me
i really didn't want to play it though i
just um again would have played it when
it came out can't really use my hands
yet
one step at the time
i know there are a lot of games who have
multiple composers
um but i found it especially interesting
in detroit become human
that each of the three playable
characters had a different composer
uh they were also color graded
differently they had different
um framing techniques they basically had
a dp
work on that game um which is something
commonly used in you know
hollywood films but they actually use
that when making detroit become human
to make it so that each character was
shot differently uh according to
the situation they're in like cara is is
usually framed within
workers like just she's very small
compared to the amount of sort of
environments that are surrounding her to
make it feel more oppressive um
grading is different the uh
like just even tones in general are
really different
between the three of them such a a thing
that most people wouldn't think about
that you know
obviously when you're making a game you
get very excited about the minor details
even if no one notices them i just think
it's really cool
would i recommend short become human um
despite saying all of that
i think it's fine there are certainly
some people who will really like it
some people who probably won't care for
it but uh
i didn't love the game overall um
i felt it was a bit a bit cheesy
they've also never really liked the walk
and talk games which
this is technically one of those but um
when it's spooky
i can get a bit more on board
the front gate was locked up that checks
out i needed to find another way in
who each
cora 20 what does it say
[ __ ]
or who reach
who knows anyone home
i guess not
cute jerky [ __ ] dork
[Music]
cool thank you great okay
read news says hello you would love it
here my dear amazing day room for the
kids and free art lessons lots of
families and the hotel is huge i've
never seen anything like it wish you
could be here with me miss uf
that's super cute i love that for you
what the hello
thomas oh is this pokey man
he's still there no no let's try one
more time catch my god
i'm still there oh my god where did he
go
how could that have happened i was
looking just a second ago
okay you really we couldn't just jump
oh it wants me to go outside and around
got it got it got it game design
oh there is a staircase there no
that is not a staircase disregard
district disregard
all right let's go shall we you want to
keep me up neva
thank you iso stardust have a good one
they're gonna have to do better than
that joy
whatever it is
it used to be a government-owned
vacation resort
that's troubling i'm not a fan of
something being government owned
an urban legend was born not capacity
the neva massacre the details were
always
fuzzy crazed workers ancient curses
you know the usual
a ball
a little girl all of the most terrifying
things in one setting
my gosh
but why what do i even want it for
i don't know ah i see there are
footsteps on the ground
i wonder if they uh well i mean she's
going on the only path so i don't know
that they need them but
let me tell you blair witch sure is set
in the woods
and does have um some light tracking
mechanics what was that
what was that what was that what's that
what's this t plus
k 1968.
you didn't there wasn't even a tiny body
that wanted to write 1969
not even a little bit
surely
she's still going the only way i can
walk we'll take it
good stuff
they're doing a very good job of
directing me through where i'm supposed
to go here i'll say that much
like the path is clear
just by virtue of the way the trees are
designed it's like an old fort
it might be my way in there's an old
fort outside this government-owned hotel
the mystery thickens
i should have said plot but then i yeah
i committed
we saw this in the in one of the
gameplay trailers as well
okay cool let's go
jesus christ oh gosh
great cool no i'm fine don't worry about
it story to tell
well i guess i was there to listen
no i'm doing good i'm doing good i
didn't get scared it's fine
don't worry about it
dead it's interesting
like everything else in this place yeah
that's cool
huh i don't feel like i'd seen them show
off
the way that works
oh she cute
okay cool cool cool cool
i wonder if i can just walk through
there in the um spirit world
the place felt old and soaked in misery
figures i guess a thousand i like that
the button bumps are different depending
on which room you're looking at it's
paid for
but even in the deepest darkness that's
cool
light can linger lonely
fragile waiting for someone to implement
she definitely reminds me of the um
as i absorbed the energy i wondered who
it was that left it
protagonist of control a dying soldier
whispering the name of his beloved
or maybe just glad to be done with this
world
oh wow i didn't even notice that
backdrop of all the figures
that's really cool super neat
very very cool
yeah jesse faden
just the vibe is similar to to control
in general like someone
journeying to a creepy building
in any case i figured i could use it
okay
so then it's probably gonna be
[Music]
all right we'll take it these powers of
mine
as much of a pain in the ass as they
were
they did come in handy sometimes
i mean did i open the gate is it good do
i need to interact with that at all
i'm not entirely sure
brilliant my gosh we've done it
um ooh congrats scooterman gaming
that's very exciting for you
pip wizard yeah i do stream late because
of work hours so i do
miss the uk a lot but i will say it's
not that uncommon for me to stream at
midnight
it is existing it is a thing that i
never really
do somewhat frequently but i know i
would have to stream earlier
for people in the uk but um alas i have
job
i have tried to stream on lunch breaks
before but
the truth is i should i mean the truth
is i should
stop and take a break and eat lunch but
usually i just want to keep working so
you know
a fork in the road you say
oh
oh what happened to you
a good question nothing for me to
identify
oh oh okay bye
i hope you just taken a nap i like to
think that's what's happening
you're just you're just sleeping it's
very peaceful maybe i come wake you
later
you'll be okay
it's another fork well you want me to go
this way so i'm just gonna i'm just
gonna go this way then
am i using microsoft's adaptive
controller to play this game
no i am using my
elite um i love this controller
and yes it is hurting my hands quite a
bit but they do
work now uh they're just very weak and
sore and uh
it's been kind of crappy not being able
to play video games probably for three
weeks
what the hell
yeah i'm not a fan of that
no no i'm i'm good i'm good actually i'm
just gonna piece out of that
let's we're just gonna walk
the other direction
[Music]
camera thank you okay good day
creepy monkey shrine i have woods to
wander something scary is gonna happen
you're not gonna do this [ __ ] camera
angle without trying to [ __ ] me
a vlog what could i do oh
it's just a tree at what point does a
tree become a log is it when it has been
logged does it have to go through the
process of logging to become a log and
cease being a tree
i was having a profound discussion just
now
okay you can't just throw this something
jesus
oh my gosh
now i will never decide what i think
neither is the difference between a log
and
just a tree that fell over the aura in
that place
rude of you to interrupt i've seen
others like it but never this
intense i think
they're very pretty earlier was the rain
it uh attracts
jesus christ
thank you
i appreciate it
oh my god
it's just it's just light keeps scaring
me
ah [ __ ] and i'm trying not to flinch at
all because
my bones will hurt anybody i shouldn't
be doing this
this is a terrible idea
locked obviously there's got to be
another way
oh yeah i don't know why you even tried
when there's a chain on it big dummy
ooh what's that what's this ah
i think there's a broken window up there
if only i could read it what are you
putting down [ __ ]
the handle's missing maybe i could
replace it with something
okay okay okay we got options well i've
already proven my
got it okay you need me to find a handle
huh
it's true malibu lizard when i flinch my
buns out
putting on pants has been the most
difficult thing for me lately
like it can hurt for hours if i put on
pants too fast
sometimes you just want to put on pants
without being in pain you know it's just
it's just a whole thing and then there's
this creepy little girl
laughing who i'm actually not
afraid of because um
you already saw her
in the thing and she's not spooky that's
a dead end
okay okay okay we ain't getting money no
way
all right cool yeah yeah sorry i keep
yawning it's my bad
you know it's midnight or whatever what
time is it
it's 104 i'm sorry about that
hey old timer now what's a
fine machine like you doing in a place
like this you think she wants to [ __ ]
this car
who's that is that what's happening
doubling is a spare bedroom apparently
she hidden on this car right in front of
us
not gonna kick shane do whatever you
want hope you don't mind if i uh
pop your trunk
i feel like i should leave do you need
time to get yourself go
do i need to be opposite much hair yeah
give me that oh no
[ __ ] what the hell
that's [ __ ] up good day i
i will return to you with lubricant
later
right now i need to open a door and drag
a dumpster and climb through a window to
get inside this
dilapidated building you know as
we all do you know just we've all been
there
did a phone ringing
nope okay
this is fine what could go wrong
yeah boom
so began the great dumpster heist of
1999.
you think you got jokes
you're a medium nobody's paying you to
do jokes i feel like i just
always want to note that for the record
i make fun of every game
it doesn't mean i don't like it i just
make fun of everything at all times
always
starting to get tired of your [ __ ] neva
um but sometimes i think it comes across
that way no it's just
it's more of me and who i am as a person
okay let's get it's pretty good upper
body strength if you ask me i could not
do that right now
why did why did you put a vignette on it
where did it get all black on the
outside oh god oh that's
well that's a brisk you just took
sorry
hmm
cool boots all right we made it inside
we've done it we finished the video game
cool
i would definitely do this um
break into an abandoned hotel 100 would
do this
nope all right again i think this is the
thing we we saw in the uh
gameplay trailer correctly i know what's
going to happen here right
anyone thomas no there was this
screaming shoe
you there that was around here somewhere
the shoe that screams
who is this cute boy the polish legends
of the dragon
wall hill
i love him um i'm just trying to find
this shoe from the
the gameplay trailer here we go here we
go
iconic
iconic i am curious about what happened
here
so it's true the neva massacre
i need to find this thomas guy and get
the hell out of here
yeah it seems weird that he didn't like
meet you outside or something he's
probably dead
that would be my guess is that he's dead
and he found a way to contact her
or something
okay damn all right
damn girl
yeah all right can i put that in my
pocket for
later don't worry about it don't worry
about it
this screams with the xbox achievement
sound you're right it's a beautiful
contrast
an interesting mix of sands a real
a front oh thank you another one
[Music]
what is that one for oh wow
again they're aggressive because nobody
else has played the game yet this is my
life i feel like i so rarely get
achievements that aren't diamond
achievements
and it's it's they're all just screaming
at me all the time
where is mike inslin i feel so pathetic
and ugly bruh same
same oh sorry laying here oh can't
relate i'm sitting
in my cyberpunk show all right stop
asking me about the chair
a boy's best friend is his mother that's
cute
someone just wrote tralala
i am cat and i'm liking my balls
hmm wonderful
all right i
cool
so i think we tried to open this and
then yeah this is definitely
the gameplay trailer
hello heck oh heck oh heck
thomas helen
i'd be spooked as hell if i didn't know
what happens for the record
i'd be easy marianne i would be done for
it's just a good old-fashioned haunted
hotel
calm your ass down and answer the belt
yeah that's
um perfectly normal that happens to me
every time i ring a bell
again i knew and i'm still scared you
startled
sadness is that your name
i mean you seem pretty cheerful to me
well it's what i remember
my friends used to call me by a
different name
but i don't remember what it was
your friends oh yeah i used to have a
lot of friends here
but they're all gone
same bro 20 20 vibes did something
happen to them
can relate i don't really want to talk
that's okay how am i liking it um so
be do you live here controls are a
little off all by yourself
from for how i feel it like i have to
like be very specific about where i
point look
um i can imagine but i'm definitely
really interested and i i like it
yeah place yeah i'll finish it for sure
oh yes
so busy people
coming and going
all the time always someone to play with
must have been nice it was
again 20 20 vibes dude same
so i used to go outdoors
tell me what happened
anything comparable gameplay-wise i
would say it's
i mean it's not terribly dissimilar to
like a player which
combined with a dark note game i would
say
maybe even super probably supermassive
zoo best bet but
the dual world things is really unique
i'm interested to see what they do with
it
that i can take care of myself hey
i was wondering have you seen mary
yes would you play with me
just for a little bit [ __ ] no
it's been so long you weird [ __ ] hell
nah but i need your help i would rather
do anything
else i bet she stinks
yes
let me think i wonder why they do the
masks
curious if there's an orange enough for
that if it means something
the second floor we can look there come
on
wait i can't go that way
damn i need to get up there somehow
yes
i think i might need to leave it there
thank you for the achievement
um obviously usually i would stream for
a lot longer but uh
it is 1 14 am and i feel like i should
go back to sleep
if you guys like watching this i'd be
down to play it again on stream it's
relatively easy to play
um definitely does hurt my hands i'm not
going to pretend that that's not a thing
because they're so weak right now uh
[Music]
but it's not super intense and not a lot
of button mashes which is what i would
not be able to do so
yeah i'm not gonna acknowledge
a raid i don't know who raided me i
guess i missed it who
who gave me a raid thank you to whoever
did that
but i think i did not see it
um yeah thank you all for watching this
this random
midnight stream it's extra spooky all my
lights are out
my apartment's not very scary though so
i'll be fine all right i will see you
guys next time